et nous sommes au téléphone avec un
l'historienne tallinn ter-minassian
bonjour n'est pas un hasard si la
première prière musulmane se déroule
aujourd'hui
racontez nous eh bien écoutez j'ai pu
voir comme vous je dis comme des
téléspectateurs je les imagine ces
images qui nous semblent effectivement
d'une main extraordinaire violence
symbolique qui est donc cette image de
cette plus grande basilique de la
chrétienté vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure pour longtemps dans ton en milan
et donc reconverti en mosquée donc j'ai
été je pense comme beaucoup de monde
assez choqué par cette image de l toran
et de ses sbires masqué en leurs
lunettes noires entrant sur le parvis et
pénétrant dans dans la mosquée et donc
on ne peut commenter de telles images
quand quant à quillan encore une fois
7,7 cette violence toute assez
extraordinaire maintenant néanmoins
j'aimerais quand même rappeler un
certain nombre de choses car en fait le
statut de cette de cette basilique a
longtemps été modifiées vous l'avez dit
elle a été reconverti par le droit de
l'épée par le droit du coude et
conquérante sûr que qui ont pris dix ans
était tombé constantinople en 14 153 et
qui donc à cette époque là on conte on
convertit cette basilique en mosquée et
ce statut donc à perdurer jusqu'à la la
fin de l'empiré ottoman enfin on sait
malgré tout cas la salle empire ottoman
le gouvernement jeune turc était quand
même un petit peu embarrassé par ce par
ce monument et que d'ailleurs il a même
été envisagé de le de le faire sauter et
puis finalement au début des années
vingt lorsque mustapha kemal a fini par
construire ce qu'on appelle la turquie
moderne avec toutes ses contradictions
d'ailleurs il a été assez tardivement
décidé finalement en 1934 d'en faire un
musée musée signifiant donc toutes
sortes de choses finalement à la fois
que cet édifice appartient effectivement
d'une certaine manière au patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité non ça c'est aussi
un petit peu en bidule la muséification
d'un édifice religieux c'est aussi une
forme de mise à mort selon moi est donc
enfin normand à ce statut de musée
permettait de garder une sorte d'entre
deux symbolique et qui a perduré donc
jusqu'à cette décision tout à fait
récente qui intervient d'ailleurs dans
un contexte politique bien particulier
donc c'est évidemment une décision
politique
néanmoins alors une décision politique
qui d'ailleurs avait été portée par un
député nationaliste mais qui
n'appartient pas à la cape et c'est un
député du mhp yusuf halaçoglu le parti
du parti de l'action nationaliste qui il
ya quelques années avait fait sept
cette proposition qui bien entendu remet
en cause l'application du soi-disant
sacro saint principe de la laïcité qui
manifs et qui est donc abouti
aujourd'hui de manière de manière assez
comment dire enfin éclatante en tout cas
du point de vue du pouvoir en place
alors vous voyez ces images en direct de
l'ex basilique sainte-sophie plusieurs
milliers de fidèles musulmans sont
réunis en ce moment même on a beaucoup
entendu parler de cette nostalgie de
l'empiré ottoman de la part du président
turc er douane est ce que c'était aussi
une demande de la population turque
cette transformation en mosquée l'une
demande enfin sans doute
elle donnera qui a longtemps cultivé
cette image de nouveau sultan de l'
empire ottoman et lui trouve ici bien
entendu à un moyen de 2 chère mais le
timing est un petit peu curieux c'est à
dire à un moment donné il était porté à
la fois par le contexte de politique
intérieure et par la politique
internationale véritablement sur les com
comme le nouveau sultan moderne cette
image là était quand même un petit peu
écornée écornée depuis l'an je pense en
effet que il dit à l'ats ils cherchent
comment dire à remédier à une certaine
situation politique qui fait que la
capter a perdu quand même pas mal de une
partie de son électorat comme on l'a vu
lors des élections municipales
de 2009 il faut quand même rappeler que
lors de ces élections municipales du 23
juin 2009 et bien istanbul a été perdu
pour la kpc donc à un candidat du chv
extrême imams aux loups du parti
républicain du peuple qui a donc été élu
maire d'istanbul et notamment et
d'ailleurs il faut rappeler que la cape
est donc le partido ham a été perdue
notamment dans des quartiers qui étaient
autrefois de ses fiefs c'est à dire
jusqu d'un pari ce qu elle se trouvant
en asie mais aussi le quartier de
fatigue et faty c'est le quartier où se
trouvent les justement les plus grandes
mosquées d'istanbul notamment
sultanahmet et caetera et tu en fasses
bien entendu vaisselle qui étaient là
bâti dick le musée sainte sophie et qui
devient aujourd'hui une mosquée et donc
et donc il ya là si vous lui une manière
de reprendre de de reprendre possession
de la ville d'une autre façon avec
l'avènement d'une supposément d'une
grande portée symbolique au président
beaucoup pour votre regard talent et une
ter-minassian historienne